da staunen nicht nur star trek fans
mitten in der hellas tiefebene dem
größten impact grad war das maß hat die
mars sonde mars reconnaissance orbiter
eine wirklich kuriose aufnahme gemacht
es ist das bild einer erhebung die
wirklich täuschend echt an das bekannte
logo von star trek erinnert wie ist es
auf den roten planeten gekommen und
warum ging twitter deswegen steil klick
zum science fiction gibt es täglich
faszinierendes science videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasste nichts
herzlich willkommen und danke für euren
themenvorschlag über telegram die nasa
selbst twitter zu ihrer neuesten
entdeckung enterprise single make the
discovery service features look konkurs
lee the famous logo übersetzt also in
etwa so was wie aufmerksame beobachter
könnten bemerken dass das hier aussieht
wie ein bekanntes logo enterprise in ist
in diesem zusammenhang ja ein wirklich
passende wortwitz be me down thomas
cottier oder was aber jetzt mal im ernst
nicht nur eingefleischte star trek fans
werden wohl auf der aufnahme der nasa
sonde mars reconnaissance orbiter
das logo von star trek erkennen können
inmitten der sanddünen des mars also
eine wirklich kuriose entdeckung auf
fachleute haben sich damit intensiv
beschäftigt und stellen jetzt klar dass
die ähnlichkeit zu dem star trek logo
wohl purer zufall ist entstanden ist
diese faszinierende maß formation wohl
durch langwierige geologische prozesse
aufgespürt wurde sie im bereich der
hellas tiefebene dem größten
einschlagskrater des mars auf seiner
südlichen hemisphäre er ist etwa 2200
kilometer x 1600 kilometer groß und hat
eine elliptische form mit seiner tiefe
von neun kilometern handelt es sich um
die tiefste region des roten planeten
auf ihrer webseite erklärt die nasa die
entstehung dieser sogenannten chef ron
formen die die experten und expertinnen
auch als dünen abgüsse bezeichnen
demnach sind sie das ergebnis eines
komplexen zusammenspiels von wind lava
und dünnen alles begann mit einer
sichelförmigen bühne die sich zu einer
insel im lava mehr entwickelte diese
sichelförmigen dünnen werden in der
fachsprache auch als bühnen bezeichnet
auf dem mars machen sie einen großteil
der
hinaus irgendwann er startete die lava
und die bühnen ragten weiter aus er
hervor
durch den wind wurde der sand weggeweht
und diese fußspuren verblieben in der
lava eben aber auch andere fachleute
beschäftigt diese entdeckung zum
beispiel captain kirk im self also
william shatner der twitterte am 13 juni
2009 10 star wars milieu ab level street
view vom star wars twitter-account kamen
dann schnell die recht eindeutige
antwort star wars the way from the time
the planet sogar mark hamill der luke
skywalker in krieg der sterne spielt
gibt seinen senf zu der entdeckung auf
dem mars ed helms 11 looks like going to
me übrigens ist das keinesfalls eine
premiere denn schon in der vergangenheit
wurden überaus kuriose motive auf der
mars oberfläche entdeckt beispielsweise
pacman oder muppet bieker auch games of
thrones war schon auf dem roten planeten
zu gast zumindest erinnert eine aufnahme
einer staubspur auf dem mars stark an
das wappentier von haus stark dieses
muster entstand wohl durch eine staub
lawine die sich durch einen objekt ein
schlag gelöst hatte der staub hatte so
diese dunkle sandschicht freigelegt all
diese kuriosen aufnahmen stammen
übrigens von high rise diese abkürzung
steht für high resolution imaging
science experiment und befindet sich wie
gesagt an bord der sonde mars
reconnaissance orbiter
die hochauflösende kamera macht gezielt
aufnahmen von formationen auf dem mars
die durch geologische und klimatische
prozesse entstanden sind und jetzt eine
kleine pirouette auch auf dem mond
wurden während der ersten mondlandung
zahlreiche aufnahmen gemacht und am 20
juli streamen wir zwölf stunden lang
live von der mondlandung vor 50 jahren
sekundengenau mit all dem wissen dass
wir heute haben mit dabei die
astronauten gerhard thiele und reinhold
ewald die wir vorab interviewt haben und
zahlreiche wissenschafts youtuber wenn
ihnen nichts verpassen wollt dann klickt
hier unbedingt und merkt euch den steam
forum 21 uhr am samstag den 20 juli geht
es los also seid dabei und bis dann
bleibt dran